[Music]
you too it's it's very good to see you
guys you both really awesome guys and
it's fun to be here like I had a gun at
you you are awesome guys
you got a crappy attitude too good you
know the last time I saw you we were
both in Washington DC a bunch of us flew
there to honor Wilfer oh who was getting
the Mark Twain prize that's correct yeah
we all had to go on stage and and do
kind of a performance and that's right
it was on PBS and I was gonna do my my
set and I had a Ken Burns joke Ken Burns
of the Civil War series on PBS right
some was like ooh Conan's got a Ken
Burns joke you might want to check with
them so I ran it by you and you were
like you know what mine's kind of
throwaway just do yours so I did mine
and it played real nice but then I
watched it and they cut it and I heard
was because they're scared of Ken Burns
PBS has made a lot of money you know
working with Ken Burns they don't want
to offend him again he's the PBS cash
cow apparently yeah yeah
so the hell elmo's number one elmo's
number one right Ken Burns number two
numero dos so you were you were your
taste I think I don't remember the
routine exactly but it was it was funny
it wasn't a bad joke I mean do you mind
if I just like rip it off right here
yeah let's let's show PBS that we're not
scared of Ken Burns get ready Ken Burns
hey there he is
so have I not gotten laid in a while or
as Ken Burns super hot
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is it just me or does this guy look like
Rob Lowe had a three-way with Stephen
King and a goatee I can't believe they
cut that I know we're gonna wake up now
with civil war horse head reenacting
that sort of made sense
no now big announcement you said you're
not going to return to start out live
that's right it's and you've been there
how many how many seasons have you been
I did seven seasons seven seasons and I
worked there years ago back when it was
early early days of the show was mostly
on radio but it was I was just do you
are you gonna miss the late hours there
because my memories of working in Senate
Live are all about being there too like
four o'clock in the morning yeah and
there's this sort of special bond you
have with other people when you're just
there all the time definitely you know I
don't know that I'll miss it on a
day-to-day but certainly a lot of
strange things happen when you stay up
that late perfect example a buddy of
mine Rob Klein he's a writer on the show
we left probably about 5:00 a.m. after a
writing night and we live on the same
block so he shared a car home and we got
to his place it's before mine on the
block and he was like oh my gosh I
forgot my keys and I was like oh whoa
he's like I gotta go all the way back to
work all the way back to Midtown I was
like well you can just crash on my couch
if you want like it's not a big deal
he's like no I don't want to put you out
it's like really it's not a big deal if
you want it you can he's like alright
you know what that's actually really
nice I'll take you up on that thank you
I really appreciate it and then right as
we took a step off his steps
this giant gay black man just kind of
appeared out from under his stairwell
and walked up to us and looked at us
both and just handed us a condom
anyway anyway have fun we were like no
no and we realized like nothing we said
was going to convince them we weren't
about to have sex yeah so we're just
like thank you thank you
safe sex angel of the West a mythical
magical creature yeah and we we were
like man that is such a funny story and
went back to my place and just went at
it like a couple rabbits point you might
as well that was like the groundwork
have been laid we have protection laid
if someone has to be a kind of mom and
have sex with in the ass